hey everyone is game from 2015 day two
and I am joined by Lucy James who has
just seen scalebound tell us about it so
I saw the extended demo basically it's
what we saw the press conference makes
us press briefing on Tuesday very action
focus demo so they are really keen to
let you guys know let the world know
it's an action RPG really from platinum
games so very cool you are playing as
drew he's from our he's from our pencil
why he's got those like Dre beeps okay
so no it's not real he got his beats by
dre na he's got he's not coffee after
dragon planet yes he's a he's the dragon
planet of Draconis and he's like this
beast master and he can tell because his
arm is all kind of scaly that means he
is like he's bonded with the Dragons
become the Alpha you have the dragon
hunters ai-controlled making him suggest
things for to do and I can you go blow
up that watchtower or take out those
guys but there's a kind of risk reward
in doing it because if you do it then
you can use this energy called pulse to
sort of vaporize the enemy body and turn
it into gems that you can then use later
on on yourself but if you get your
dragon to do it then it just obliterate
everything and there's nothing left for
you to do so kind of way up the risk and
reward
yeah be able to easily defeat an enemy
but then you won't get the necessary
rewards
it's a very RPG it feels like an RPG is
it an open-world RPG so someone didn't
raise that question and the answer is
not really
hideki kamiya was in the presentation
and he says that the term open-world can
just mean it could mean one thing to
make I mean nothing to you so scale one
isn't gonna really be open world as we
think like I think Skyrim big
environments but not necessarily true
open well not a true open world
experience in the same way that's what
they like okay cool yeah customisation
it seemed like you didn't like what we
saw there was like picking up loot and
that kind of stuff and customizations
that they call RPGs and though RPGs is
it gonna have that is it gonna be like
pockets of customization so they show
the gameplay demo and the little trailer
for the customization options and you
can kind of customize everything so from
what weapons you carries you can carry
like your bow and arrow sword son mine
Spears the whole the whole lot such as
you the character drew and then your
dragon so you can control its evolution
you can control yeah so it's pretty cool
so it had like the picture of the dragon
and then a list of all the different
things you could change I gets horns you
could change which elemental powers it
uses so from Fire and Ice
you could change you know the coloring
on it you could get your favorite dragon
skins
you can also it did flesh up by dragon
armor but we were reassured that that
there's no microtransactions there's no
microtransactions galvan using in-game
currency by dragon armor which looks
badass
how did it perform when he was playing
certainly the press conference in the
high action bits and there are a lot of
characters in screen and you know your
dragon and just throw in a flat five all
or something the framework did stutter
honestly in the demo that I saw it ran
so much smoother it was live gameplay
there's a guy playing it it looked
really good I mean the level of detail
because this is still pre-alpha the
level of detail still isn't there it's
not what we can expect upon actual
release which is late next year but it
looked good and it played look like a
play really notice final question yeah
platinum fans expect a certain level of
combat they expect deep intricate combat
does it look like that it will have that
game or is it a little more simplified
where with RPG mechanics answer I think
it was it's probably the former because
there's obviously the hack-and-slash
kind of combat you're also getting a
dragon involved but I saw the guy who's
demoing like utilize so he picked up a
stun mine and he was taking on the giant
crafting so he chucked it at the crab
paralyzed it in the news his bow and
arrow and latched himself on while the
things paralyzed and I hooked himself on
and then you know perform like this
quick combo on its back to do a
significant amount of damage so I think
I think I've seen the term Canyon game
you could play either way but I like the
look of how things are linking together
to make a real cool I like how it's all
coming together I'm Way more excited
about it I think heard were you
than seeing it but yeah for more on
scalebound and other games games from
2015 keep your eyes on games for